all right guys bang-bang I've got David
here we have a whole bunch to go over
you are I think your last name is well
known in crypto but you are behind the
scenes quite a bit so we're gonna get
you to tell us all your secrets they got
doing this sounds like fun
all right so you had a life before
crypto let's talk about that your
background and then we can talk about
how you've built Waksman
into the giant it is today yes so way
before waxman existed all I was was a PR
agent here in New York City okay and
that means I was like every other PR
person here with essentially no
specialization we worked on I worked on
real estate development projects so if
you wanted to build the skyscraper and
you need to go and get some sort of
funding and you had some sort of
checkered past or some sort of challenge
before you need some sort of reputation
management so I'd work with companies
that were doing things like that if you
were a cosmetics firm that has a new
subscription box with the latest
greatest lipstick you needed to go and
get in the beauty publications I'd work
with them if you were selling industrial
LED lights that need to be installed in
buildings and you wanted a bit of an
edge in your sales pitch I'd work with
those types of companies - absolutely no
specialisation and it was kind of fun I
really liked learning a lot about a lot
and being able to ask very hard
questions - really brilliant people in
many different industries and when
you're launching a Middle East food
chain in the United States and you're
helping them rebrand and retitle their
products helping them figure out what
their slogans gonna be and how that's
gonna affect the crowd on Astor Place in
downtown New York as opposed to people
in Abu Dhabi and Dubai those are
compelling and interesting things to
work on but it was nothing like crypto
yeah well let's talk about what PR is in
general right so you're talking a lot
about its branding it is messaging it's
getting coverage like just walk through
how you think about PR as a discipline
in general and then we can get into kind
of how that applies to crypto
so let's start more broadly with what
marketing is so marketing is in some way
essentially taking some sort of product
or service and helping an audience of
customers understand what that product
or service is perhaps to make a
compelling case as to why they should
or utilize a product or service that's
kind of broadly what marketing is and
marketing has many many subsets
categories for instance advertising is a
part of marketing when you're gonna go
buy toothpaste how do you know with
toothpaste even exists in the first
place
well it turns out one way you buy
toothpaste the way most people do is
they'll they'll go to a store that's
experiential marketing literally the the
access they're the I should say the act
of taking a toothpaste and putting it on
the right shelf
well PR is something very different PR
is mostly in the realm of communications
it's less imagery it's less it's not
advertising the type of PR that we do is
not pay-for-play that is to say we help
companies figure out who they really are
we help them figure out a compelling
storyline a compelling narrative a
compelling brand that is gonna last
beyond a single campaign or announcement
and then we help companies get in the
real news and in things similar to that
things like for instance this podcast
where you're very very selective you
turn down almost everybody but if
something's it has a compelling story
and you think it's interesting you'll
say yes to that and so Waxman helps our
clients get into real news sources
across the world we have no favors to
pull it doesn't work that way we're not
paying anybody a penny it's by virtue of
the fact that we help take compelling
stories and make them a little bit more
interesting for the right audiences more
importantly what that does the net
effect of that is it helps businesses do
better all right I like to think of it
as handing your business card to
somebody before you ever walk in the
room in the first place and what that
means is you're more likely to get a
deal done and part of I think the PR and
the communications side is just one
clearly articulating here's what we do
here's who we are and the other and you
touch on a little bit is also
understanding what are the publications
or the media outlets that are looking
for that type of content as well right
playing matchmaker a little bit in the
sense of it's one thing about if a
company or a founder can tell their
story in a clear and articulate way it's
a whole nother thing for them to be able
to get matched up with the people who
are looking to tell that story for them
in the news as well 100% and that's from
the exposure side we'll talk about the
rest of PR including crisis
communications including how to plan for
for disaster or challenges because that
happens to with every organization but
yes in terms of gaining exposure
it's very hard to determine exactly
who's gonna care about one store one
story at any given time you might think
that this is the most newsworthy event
in the world when I talked to founders
all the time who think that what they
have is the most compelling event of all
time
but it's not necessarily and we know
because we're talking me and the
organization I work with we're talking
to reporters across the world every
single day in the verticals that matter
the types of reporters who might be
interested and I'll tell you what we are
turned down far far more often than we
are actually accepted and that's even
with very compelling stories it turns
out reporters are cynics professional
reporters have gone to journalism school
they are trained to determine what's
newsworthy they then are publishing
articles all the time and so they're
getting new types of data are readers
engaging are their editors happy with
their work are their posts getting more
loved on some of these aggregator
platforms are they getting shared on
social so that goes through from the
media side the media is determining what
works and what doesn't they also have
their own narratives they want to tell
some reporters are genuinely just
interested in some things and not
interested in others so you have to
figure out exactly what a reporter might
want to find want to find out about and
then the PR agency also has a secondary
job figure out how to tell that story to
a reporter some reporters will not get
on the phone with you they are just pure
email they are disinterested in phone
calls others they want to have a
face-to-face to know if you're lying or
not you need to really understand the
reporters what they're interested in and
do your very best in matchmake
absolutely and so let's talk about how
you took the experience in PR
communications into cryptic ones the
first time you ever saw crypto Bitcoin
what was that like so this was early
2014 and I was downtown in New York at a
bar called sweet and vicious and there
was this tech founders night going on
and I was just having a couple drinks
meeting various folks and I met the CEO
of an early Bitcoin exchange called coin
Center so for those of you who don't
know coin Center was one of the first
vc-backed exchanges digital currency
group actually an offshoot of that gave
money at the time and they had raised
about two million dollars in seed
funding so they were one of the first
exchanges that were selling Bitcoin but
the biggest exchange in the world the
time was called bitstamp which of course
is still around but most of the other
ones that you know very well did not
exist
the exchanges that did also the exact
same product Bitcoin and all them had
very low trading volumes none of them
was actually making enough money to
probably operate by themselves with just
their trading volumes alone so they were
all trying to find a way to go and get
to a series a to raise more money so
this way they could go and expand
operations because everyone building a
Bitcoin exchange had the same dream that
Bitcoin would one day become popularized
but back then it certainly wasn't this
is early 2014
just after mal Cox and I started working
with this Bitcoin exchange and I was
able to help them take their new
features like for instance the interest
was called a fix API which is a type of
way of connecting a computer system to
algorithmically or through a trading
system trade on exchange and we managed
to make a software feature like that
somewhat compelling whenever they were
able to go and get a new partnership
with a wallet or they were working with
some sort of mining pool of some type or
they were working with an ATM network
they were just starting at the time
Bitcoin ATM networks we were able to
tell that story and that exchange
although they weren't able to ever raise
that series a they were able to
successfully exit at the beany in 2016
to Kraken who I later on worked with but
that was my first foray into the Bitcoin
space I didn't know anything about
Bitcoin before that except all I had
heard was that mount GOx was a disaster
that the Silk Road existed and the
Bitcoin may or may not be used by
criminals and only by criminals that's
what I learned or knew of the for
because that's what I was reading in the
news but then I met this Bitcoin
exchange CEO and he was so smart and so
compelling and I started meeting his CTO
and then I started meeting all the
partners and what I noticed very very
swiftly as I started to read the Bitcoin
talk forums or I was going on reddit or
I was going to the Bitcoin in-person
meetups is that the average IQ of people
working in the space seemed to be a
little bit higher or maybe a lot bit
higher and consequently I felt I had to
go and find out more and so in 2015 I
started taking on other clients on the
side trying to go and start my own
agency so I brought on the Bitcoin ATM
network a software wallet hardware
wallet a mining pool and a blockchain
focused VC and launched waxman at the
end of 2015
got it and so let's talk through what
Waxman did in the beginning and kind of
what those really days were like and
then we could talk about what it's doing
today well back in the early days I was
the only person doing all the work
so I built they were called media lists
I've vetted them all I brought on all
the new business I had to set up all the
operations and then what I would do is I
would help our clients get in the news
so I would go and have personal
relationships pitching to Pete Rizzo the
editor in chief of coin desk or pitching
to the owners of Bitcoin magazines and
the editors at the time and the various
other publications that mattered there
were some beat reporters that that work
at major publications even today who
were also focused at the space at the
time people like Michael Casey who was
at The Wall Street Journal in Paul vania
nathaniel popper
Gertrude Chavez Dreyfuss at Reuters and
a number of other top reporters who were
there dan roberts at the time was it
fortunate moved over to Yahoo Finance
and these are people who with whom I
built a relationship because I was
pitching them stories and as like I
mentioned earlier the vast majority of
the time they turned me down but what
compelled me to do was to continue to
build trust with these people if they
turn me down I'd wanted to know why how
I could go and make things better the
next time make sure that I didn't spam
them or make them feel as though I was
doing anything uncomfortable I want to
be a trusted resource for them and when
I finally had that motley of clients I
suddenly became a resource if they
needed to write a story in two days time
and they needed a quote on the recent
price action the Bitcoin I could
probably get them that if there was a
security breach or a hack or something
else going on in the news they might be
reliant on one of my clients in part
because I was able to go and get them on
the phone quickly and in a professional
way and it turned out they were
interesting so that's how things started
today Waxman works with I don't know
6070 clients worldwide we work with a
large swath or the biggest brands in the
entire industry all over the world we
have offices in New York Dublin and
Singapore and we have an army of trained
staff who have been doing this for a
very long time who have that same type
of really strong relationship with many
many reporters the world over and we
built a bit of an institutional
relationship sometimes with some of
these reporters and their publications
who know that they can rely on Watson to
be a trusted resource and that's the
thing that we fight hard every single
day to maintain that's our literally our
number-one priority
and so let's walk through a customer or
a client will come to you and what are
the different types of services that
they're looking for they're looking for
kind of PR communications
crisis communications just kind of walk
us through what those services look like
yes so what we're able to offer the
following then I'll tell you what we
don't offer yet or not now I should say
right now we offer PR branding strategic
communications and crisis communications
on the PR side so we're gonna help
people with their content their own
content so that might be their blog it
might be their medium posts it might be
helping them author or edit their byline
articles are gonna be published in as
contributing publications the world over
we're gonna help them get booked on
podcasts radio interviews TV interviews
where warranted we're gonna help them go
and get into real newspapers real
magazines the online versions of these
and in such the world over we're gonna
help him get into trade publications
both whether it's in the block train
trades or in something that's let's call
it their other part of the business like
if your insurance company using
blockchain you probably have an
insurance company trade publications
that are very very important to you and
it might be in specific geographies it
might be in certain languages and will
help our clients get into those types of
publications so that's what we do on the
PR side we then noticed in 2017 as there
was a proliferation of events that it
was completely impossible for anyone
myself included to actually keep track
of what was going on in fact in 2018
there were 800 events that my events
team that it globally in the crypto
space and so what we do is we help our
clients figure out where they should go
why they should go and then we help them
with sponsorships we help them design
their booths sometimes we'll even throw
a conference we'll throw a dinner we'll
throw something a launch party on behalf
of clients and we do this all the time
so that's PR and events I'd say those
are our two primary services we've
delved Ahsan to a few other things that
were very interested in strategic
consulting similar to what Mackenzie or
BCG would do recruiting as a service I
think is very compelling to as there are
a lot of companies in the space that
need specialized people to find
specialized experts to join the industry
and I think that there's gonna be a lot
of activity there got it so let's go
right to kind of the most dramatic of
all scenes right is somebody's running a
company all of a sudden they get wind or
maybe even a story breaks that's
negative they currently do not work with
PR agency and they call you guys up and
they say just help right
walk me through those types of scenarios
as to kind of how you guys or other PR
agencies are able to help founders when
they get in that situation yeah so this
unfortunately happens quite often I can
only imagine and we'll get a call and
it's gonna be either from the founder of
one of these
whatsup projects or companies or often
from their investors mm-hm and they'll
simply say we have this problem can you
solve this and we immediately go into
crisis mode in crisis mode is a little
bit different it is there are a very few
let's call it niceties it's getting
straight to the bottom of it figuring
out exactly what we've got what the
problem is and figuring out what we can
say and then what waxman does internally
is we create a crisis playbook we do
this very very rapidly and this
basically goes and tells absolutely
every stakeholder in the organization
exactly what they can say to whom when
and how and why and we basically make
this playbook work so that there's some
sort of holding statement so if our
statement you're able to make near
instantaneously to let people know that
you're looking into the problem mmm that
you understand what the problem is
because oftentimes that's not addressed
by company's founder should know if you
are not telling the world that you
recognize a problem exists people are
going to think and they should that
there's some deep-seated problem that
might be actually much worse than the
actual crisis itself so you need to go
and have some sort of statement that way
and at that point in time you may have
bought yourself a little bit of time
during this period of time an internal
investigation often goes on we do our
best to assist with that but more
importantly we do our best to help
figure out what can be said into the
right party it might be that there's one
trusted journalist who you're gonna be
able to tell the nuanced version of your
story to someone who is going to ask you
hard questions but they'll be fair and
so we may identify a reporter that we
might want to work with in this case it
might be that you want to make a very
bold statement you might have a large
community on telegram you might have a
large community there's globally in
different foreign different languages
and we'll create a playbook for how
messages would be disseminated and when
and the reason that matters is you're
trying to prevent panic from occurring
and panic occurring has all sorts of
knock-on effects that you don't want to
have
and unfortunately done this many times
for companies I can't really talk about
all the cases I can't talk probably
about some but suffice to say I feel
like some of the greatest
accomplishments we've had so far or when
we've taken a really large crisis or
what could have been a large crisis and
minimized it making it easier for the
business to succeed give me an example
of like what type of negative press
right what I really want to get at is I
want founders to listen to this and
understand here's how you can
communicate here are ways to do it
effectively here are things to avoid
doing right kind of really walk away
with with a bunch of tips from it but
what are the scenarios where when
somebody calls well there's that founder
or that investor and they're like help
is it somebody's you know there's a
nasty tweet about a company is it that
there's actually like a hit piece
written in the media like I'll give you
a few but yeah give me some example how
about a hack just occurred the current
exchange so that's happened before yep
or and they're calling and saying we
just got hacked news is spreading how do
we basically control the narrative and
and immediately address it but literally
what do we do period they often don't
know exactly what to do they know that
they have their tech team working on
this they know that things are blowing
up on Twitter they know things are
blowing up on telegram they don't know
exactly who to talk to and what to say
yep because here's the thing it's very
easy to make a huge colossal mistake the
first thing founders should understand
is every time you talk to the press they
will remember they will call you out on
that so never say something that you
might have to revert and change your
opinion on 24 hours later 36 hours later
six months later simply don't make
predictions don't say something that's
not absolutely factual it's okay to be
repetitive in word choice you don't need
to be poetic but what's most important
is being very very clear
the more you obfuscate things the more
you're confusing the more people will
think that something else is going on
once again they have a compelling reason
to do so but so it might be a hack it
might be some sort of other crisis let's
say for instance founders leaving the
company or someone just got sick or
there was some sort of let's say massive
drop in price of something or a report
came out from a newspaper painting
an incredibly bad light what do you do
in these scenarios
so there are play books for this as to
say much of this has happened before and
you can use those types of examples to
help craft the best possible way out if
you are for instance replacing one
founder with a new executive there might
be better ways than others to go and
talk about the way that a founder is is
changing positions it might be when a
hack occurs that you're able to actually
convince people to not immediately
withdraw all their funds because it
might have been that you got things
under control within ten minutes and it
turned out it was just one hot wallet
and you might have some really good
reason why it happened an investigation
beyond going and you could be of
cooperating with with authorities for
instance as opposed to a thorn in their
side there's and the difference between
those two things might simply be the way
you communicate mm-hmm absolutely and so
let's go through kind of whether it's in
a crisis situation or just in
traditional communicating with
journalists of all variety both what
I'll call the professionals and the
amateurs what are the biggest mistakes
you see founders makes your to describe
kind of this idea of they say things
that aren't factual or they may have to
change their mind on but what what's
kind of the tips that you give these
founders in terms of hey when you're
talking to the media here's what you
should do here's the first problem I see
with founders this happens universally
in every continent founders want to make
reporters engage with them and so they
tend to tell them things they shouldn't
by that I mean they pre announced stuff
all the time God and this is I can't
explain how important this is
once information is out information is
out that prevents it for being news news
is literally about being new so if
something exists on the internet and a
reporter who has the capability of using
Google simply searches a term once
you've made a press release and it turns
out you said that in a blog post in a
newsletter you said this out loud and
someone wrote about it on the Internet
they are very unlikely to write about it
and it the amount of exposure we'll get
from your actual press release will be
greatly minimized that's the first
mistake just shut your mouth talk when
you're when you really should don't say
things when you shouldn't
beyond that be completely honest and be
polite
with journalists I can't tell you how
important it is to be polite there are
some founders out there that for some
reason tend to be combative with
reporters I don't see any reason to do
so these people are not your friends but
they are professionals who are trying to
do a job just be polite with them it
will go a very long way I know those two
things seem pretty simple don't say
we're not supposed to and be polite but
you might double or triple the exposure
you'll get if you just do that for a
little while
yeah well and part of it too is you know
look we've had plenty of founders over
the years that we've invested in they
have some sort of interview and I've
seen the mistakes on I'm thinking of one
specific example where the founder
literally was saying the truth with no
spin no what we can call that I think
poetic articulation just very factual
but was innocence proud of what the
company had done it's in the healthcare
space and the reporter to their credit
took what the founder said and wrote
about it right and the way that the
article was written was ended up having
a negative connotation even though the
reporter wasn't attacking or kind of
writing you know I sort of hid job
it was just that the way that the
founder described what they were doing
was in a very kind of non sensitized way
so I think I know what you mean what it
comes down to is people may have a
founder has a very unique vision it is a
focused vision and what it's very
important to have if not a PR agency
then someone from the outside looking in
to tell you how the rest of the world is
gonna view what it is you have to say so
for instance in your example you the
founder may have had a very compelling
argument and it might have been a truly
wonderful thing given all the context
given his philosophy or her philosophy
that might be the case but a reporter
may come in and say the innovation that
you have turns out to be extremely
dangerous or that it may have other
types of effects that are are really
negative or it might be that grandma in
Iowa may look at the exact same set of
facts and have a very different
perspective so a PR agency is meant to
and we do this all the time tell-tell
our clients know you
can't say this I know it's compelling
but if you do this here is how other
people will view this instead you might
want to frame it a certain way in order
that the same information can get across
but the very least you're presupposing
the questions others are gonna ask to
prevent it from being a complete
disaster that happens very often we see
yeah
well and so one is like they are focused
and they're proud of the work and then
by the way they should be proud of the
work done it's just the way that you
talk about it is important the other and
they mentioned is the combativeness
right and from what I've seen founders
spend too many hours of too many days
working on what they believe is one of
if not the most important things in the
world and so they're emotionally
attached and they're obviously biased in
terms of what they're building and I
think that when reporters ask pointed
questions or frankly just tough
questions honest fair questions right
founders can feel like they're being
attacked right or unfairly kind of
questioned and that's where the
combativeness comes from and I think
that your framing of like look they are
simply trying to do their job and their
job is not to you know kind of promote
your company their job is actually to
raise very important facts so let's talk
about that for a second here it's
differs between advertising and PR mm in
advertising you are paying for a spot
mm-hmm which is a wonderful thing if you
are a supermarket you absolutely should
be hosting advertisements for the food
production companies that are
essentially selling their wares in your
store but if you are a newspaper you
have two different sections you have the
advertising sections and then you have
the news section the reporters are
absolutely not there to promote what you
have to say that's what the advertising
section is for if you want to go and
take out an ad they would say be my
guest go pay sixty thousand dollars for
a full-page ad and we're happy to go and
put this on page a7 but if you want to
be in the news section
well the journalists and the editors
they've got all the control and they're
not there to promote they're there to
tell what they think is an interesting
story to the audience that they happen
to have and it's very important to know
when you're going into an interview this
is another tip for founder's make sure
to know who the reporter is
what they typically write about who
their audience is and what they're
interested in if you're not briefed on
that before you go in you may be talking
either over their head or you may be
radically oversimplifying something if
you're talking to a technical expert and
you're just giving the high level and
you're sorry you're talking about your
new scalability protocol and all you're
talking about is how Bitcoin works you
know if to have compelled to a technical
reporter they're not gonna care at all
don't never write about you but if
you're trying to go and explain
something very very technical and
sophisticated that only caters to the
world's smallest audience and you're
telling this to a reporter at USA Today
that has an audience of people that stay
at the Holiday Inn mm-hmm well you're
doing it wrong absolutely and I guess
part of this also is as founders get
more comfortable talking to the press
well you see this with you know folks
that first time they go on television
right or the first time they give an
interview it is a very raw
it is very just kind of blunt and honest
right and then when you see somebody you
know I think you and I would consider
they are professional in terms of
engaging with the media it's not that
they are lying in any way it's not that
they are hiding factual information they
just have become very you know in tune
with how to engage with the media how to
present information in a way that is
easily consumable by the end reader or
listener or watcher but then also how to
give information to a reporter in a
format and kind of framing that they're
able to use in their stories because
it's something else that I've seen a lot
and I think you know I've talked about
previously is like most founders I get
the sense of they're basically telling
the reporter their stories if the
reporter is the end consumer right
instead they need to understand that the
reporter is there to get information
from you so they can write a story
you're providing them the tools right
and then the reporters gonna go do their
job which is a little bit different I
think it's very different so two major
things to take from that the first is
yes reporters are gathering facts to
write their own story they are not
republishing your press release it will
not look or feel exactly like the press
release that you may have issued or the
statements that you're making
precisely they're gonna take their own
spin on things that's what they do and
they're storytellers and they're using
your facts as part of telling a story
there are some reporters that don't
write about announcements at all it
might be folded into a trend story of
some type or they might be talking about
several different companies you
shouldn't take that as an insult that's
simply how they tell stories to their
audience
the second major thing is yes founders
they tend to not necessarily be media
trained or not think that they need it
media training is a service that waxman
does for its clients and the reason we
do it is it has a huge effect on what
the outputs gonna be one of the things
that we tell people is speak in short
sentences if you aren't able to get your
point across fairly quickly it's not
gonna be something people can remember
if you it might be and I have spent some
time with founders they cannot just
speak but they think in paragraphs and
even pages at a time but no one that
they're talking to is gonna be able to
absorb all that information and turn
into something compelling talk about
things in small staccato-like sentences
explain things in a clearer way make
sure someone fully gets it before you
move on to the more advanced or or next
topic absolutely
so let's talk about that there's a lot
of companies of various sizes that you
guys work with right everything from
some of the largest companies in crypto
down to smaller teams
let's talk though about kind of you know
the person who's you know one two three
people they haven't raised any money
they've kind of just built you know what
we can't really call it company yet
right it's more of like a project that
they've built they're trying to get some
awareness for it any tips for those
types of people as to things that they
can do you know kind of as my my partner
Jason Lewis would say ballin on a budget
anything there that you think could
could help them absolutely so the first
thing that they should do is figure out
what they have that's unique so it turns
out the same thing that may peak
investor interest might peak reporter
interest and then make sure that focus
on just that if you're gonna be
announcing I'm assuming that you have at
least something beyond a white paper
some sort of working product some sort
of user base figure out who that user
base is figure out who that would be
attractive to and those the reporters
that you should be talking to so for
instance if you're if you have a crypto
project
and you might have something a little
bit faster look better or that supports
one of the the major blocking protocols
start with that target audience so if
you're all about Yoast you're all that
EOC if you're all about hash graph all
the hash graph and look think look like
googling and see who are the reporters
that write about that ecosystem mmm
pitch of those people and again pitching
a very compelling and brief way tell
them exactly what you have see if
they're interested in learning more and
then if they are give them more
information exactly what they ask for
not any more than that don't flood them
don't spam them just give them that type
of information that's one to recognize
that what is newsworthy over time well
it gets more challenging so in crypto
two years ago if you said that you were
a middle manager at some large
enterprise company and you were behind
some sort of project that was compelling
news they people couldn't believe that
something was that was a mid-level
manager at Amazon was getting into
crypto well about three weeks ago or a
month ago my company announced that the
former prime minister of Denmark who
then became Secretary General of NATO
was joining the advisory board of a
company that is how much things have
gotten more sophisticated in blockchain
so you should recognize that your
announcement if it's closer the first
and the second it's probably not going
to be that compelling I'm not saying
that you need to have a prime minister
to come on board Barack Obama does not
need to be on your board of directors
but you do need to recognize what you've
got and then be okay with what you'll
get as a result yeah and it feels like a
lot of what you guys deal with is what
I'll call more like the professional
media right so this is you know large
publications everything from television
to print to podcast et cetera but also
professionally trained reporters how
does social media fit into all of this
right it's this platform that is so
intertwined in crypto and there's so
much conversation and everyone seems to
be there on the telegram the right it's
the Twitter's how do you look at that
so I think social is fascinating and
it's absolutely evolved it wasn't too
long ago that everyone was on slack
until people realized that slack was
exactly how people could pretend to be
Vitalik and ask for aetherium and then
it they went to rocket chat and then
they went to discord and now people are
suddenly on telegram which is which is
pretty great but the conversations
themselves
I'm not sure that they've entirely
evolved the crowd sometimes are just
enormous it's very hard to keep track of
everything that's going on every
telegram channel in fact I'd be
interested to know the average person in
crypto how many different telegram chats
they're subscribed to at any given time
and how many they actually read well I
was gonna say forget subscriptions how
many do they actually open let's say on
a daily basis I bet you it's less than 5
I'm sure it is but there might be one or
two they're their favorites where
they're a huge contributor and what's
really important from my perspective is
that the messaging be the same for all
platforms if you are trying to tell a
story or you have some sort of
announcement or there's some sort of
crisis make sure to go and deliver the
same message everywhere or at least a
derivation of it that has the exact same
general concept because if you're
feeding one channel one one set of
information in another channel another
well you're in dudes are gonna confuse
people and what then happens is people
stop trusting your company and once they
stop trusting you everything else falls
apart
absolutely and keep on that thread for a
second about trust right how much of the
communications of a organization are
about getting the end user potential
customers or a partner's whatever to
trust the company versus the individuals
right like you know if you think of
Facebook right there's the company and
there's Mark Zuckerberg Sheryl Sandberg
and a whole host of other folks if you
think of Twitter there's Twitter then
there's Jack Dorsey right where's the
line there and is there a kind of a
sequential type strategy of you want
people to trust the founder and then the
company or the company than the founder
how does that work that's a fantastic
question so all I do is ask great
questions come on
well this one's very interesting and
I'll tell you why it turns out a lot of
companies have absolutely no brand
appeal at first they have none they have
a new name they are still have a product
it might be let's say
not-ready-for-prime-time you can't do
reviews on products and aren't out yet
so therefore you have to trust something
something has to be compelling and you
might want to build to a crescendo
moment when a product is released when
it's finally available so how do you get
reviews for a product six months down
the road when you have no brand today
well what you often do is you start with
building what's called thought
leadership and you hear this concept a
lot and I
it sounds incredibly tacky but it comes
down to is reporters themselves six
months from now are more likely to go
and open up an email from about someone
that they've heard of before that
they've talked to you before to
potentially write a review of this
product to come down six months if they
knew that person in the first place so
how do you build that personal brand and
narrative that's what thought leadership
that means making someone expert that
means getting them to comment on news of
the day if they have an expertise if
they have the right academic background
utilize that if someone's worked as a
PhD in theoretical physics and they've
worked on the motion of asteroids and
deep space for instance those types of
people maybe we could talk about space
but they could probably talk about a few
other things that are related to physics
or things where physics suddenly gets
into the whole blockchain space that
gives them enough of an expertise
they'll listen talk and opine about
other topics in the future if they write
an article which I'd like a byline
article or not that if they're able to
publish one two three five of them
suddenly they might have a bit of an
audience on social so when we're
reporter down the road is looking to
figure out should they write a story on
some pitch that came through the door
that person might look more compelling
it's all about building that personal
narrative that then transmutes and
essentially provides brand value and
wrecking and that brand equity I should
say to this company that down the road
needs to do and have a product launch
yeah and I mean look what you're talking
about and I'm thinking out loud here is
I've noticed that as founders social
followings have increased in size it's
like this self-fulfilling prophecy all
of a sudden different media outlets
everything from you know the really
large professional ones all the way down
to kind of industry type publications
write about them more and my hunch has
always been that if somebody has a large
social following the media wants to
write about them because then that
person will share the article and
they'll get it more traffic that's 100%
the case you gotta remember media has
been essentially consolidating because
there's no money in media right now and
we've seen that over and over again
reporters don't get paid nearly enough
letters don't get paid nearly enough and
they're looking for ways to compete in
an increasingly small market because
there's so much free content out there
and near free content out there that
they're competing with this is the
problem with the internet so yes they
absolutely
do care about how big a following you
have and if you aren't someone who was
in the White House or 10 Downing Street
but you have 500,000 Twitter followers
you still might get covered yeah it's
pretty crazy to see I think how
individuals have used this right and
it's not just crypt I mean look you know
one of the best examples I think is is
Austin at lambda school is doing a
fantastic job and and it goes back to
this idea of like there's a level of
authenticity and transparency while
still understanding the boundaries of
which to operate right I think that what
you're describing in terms of look
there's a lot of times we're saying
nothing actually maybe the right
strategy or ways to promote or present
information that is well-received by
media but then there's the levels of
authenticity and transparency right and
I think that that balance is really hard
to strike it's fascinating to me that
some people are just natural at it right
and so there are these some companies
have their own brand narrative so Kraken
has their own voice on social and I
think it's a fantastic voice that
they've been able to to basically put
together it's a company voice it's not
just Jesse Powell's love his voice he's
fantastic but it's they have their own
kind of company narrative and that
shines through their social and it feels
authentic and they can be playful they
can be very very technical and serious
but it comes off right there are other
companies that simply don't have that
and you need to build that over time yep
what you need to do I think is gain
trust I talked about that earlier in it
and I think that we should keep coming
back to trust with their audience or
with their potential audience and the
way with with you say something is one
way to go and establish trust just as
much as the content of what you say
mm-hmm I mean look if you look at you
know let's take Kraken and bit max for
example right so cracking with the whole
bsv should they delisted should they not
like I thought it was a very clever move
on their part to ask
they literally ran a poll on Twitter and
said should we do this right and the
audience responded and the in such a
collaborative environment like crypto to
take that approach I think was pretty
cool right now people argue should they
have done it so they're not you know
whatever but I hope that just approached
to a big decision being somewhat to me
inform dress code not even the necessary
saying look like we're gonna do whatever
the community says as opposed to what by
Nance tit
were they just yeah what would she which
but but again right like I think that
you know you could make the argument
that even though finance handled it
differently finance handled it in the
way you would expect given their founder
their marketing their voice etc right
like he warned people he said he was
gonna do it right and he did it and so
like two very different approaches end
up with the same result but I think that
there certain people who are fans of
mine its who aren't fans of crackin and
vice versa and it's that's where you
gonna get it but they look at something
like a bit max right which you know I
would say their reputation is across the
board some people think they're great
they got tons of liquidity all this
stuff and some people think oh my god I
can't believe these guys are providing
all this leverage and stuff in the
ecosystem but they've got some of the
best research right like all of a sudden
you start looking at the research and
you're like I don't care what you think
about the products they're offering etc
it's hard to deny that this isn't good
work right and that's that's part of the
voice and the thought leadership I think
you're talking about but it's the
company and it is outside of Arthur
Hayes's voice which is more kind of fun
and playful and just you know he's
having he's living his life well you see
well first I'm incredibly biased because
Waxman represents bit mix but I'll say
this
Arthur is one of the smartest sharpest
people you'll ever meet
I'm sure you know him in a social level
and he's he's incredibly compelling and
he can drill down on absolutely any
subject in about 30 seconds like very
few people I've ever met mmm-hmm but
their research is phenomenal I love that
one of the things I love asking
basically any company that can gather
data is can you give me some of that
data to pitch out because reporters love
it it's a goldmine for them it lets them
create whatever narrative they want it
gives them a resource something
objective or semi objective that they
can work with and bit max is one of the
best research departments by far that
you're ever gonna find and we found that
to be an incredibly effective tool and
engaging audiences in a new way by
showing that yes there is this very very
professional research heavy side of pit
mix that many people didn't know about
before yes they built this colossal
exchange of course and tons of liquidity
and it's brought I think new dimensions
to Bitcoin in general but what they've
done with their research I think that a
lot of companies should be looking at
them and saying how can I do something
similar
how can I add something new to the
overall discussion that's actually
compelling it's not just my opinion but
something based in fact and where do you
see kind of the maybe the types of
companies that haven't been coming
forward right so like the way I
envisioned you tell me if I'm wrong he's
like 2017 was this huge boom in icos and
just a lot of nonsense right there were
lots of some good companies being built
but but for the majority of the
enterprises or a project there were just
nonsense there's a lot of money flying
around and then in 2018 we kind of have
like the perch it feels like now most of
the companies that are left have some
sort of legitimacy right now we can
argue are the right technical solutions
are the people running them you know
good or bad actors all the things that
people debate on Twitter every day but
is that what you're seeing and and how
does that translate into like the types
of clients that you guys work with right
where I'm assuming to us if you're
getting pitched by like a million ICO
projects and like maybe you're at like
zero those pitches today or maybe not I
don't know so we turned down a little
over 1000 companies last year because
that's how much was going on the ICO
space 2008 in 2018 Wow yes 2017 I
couldn't even tell you I don't think we
had an apparatus at the time to figure
that out but 2018 a little over 1,000
companies what we're seeing this year on
average is that the average company is
simply much better the potential new
business prospect their more compelling
and more professional and more
interesting and that's in part because
people have been in a space for longer
you got to remember in 2017 people that
had been in blockchain for even two
years or a few and far between
most people that simply picked us up in
late 2016 or early 2017 or when I
co-starred in the first place so let's
let's look at the numbers in 2015 when I
started waxman the total crypto market
cap was a little less than six billion
dollars so in 2017 we will start in 2016
Krypton went from about 6 billion - or 6
7 billion to 17 billion in one year so
it two-and-a-half pretty pretty big it's
great and then in 2017 it went from 17
billion to almost 800 billion dollars
which is just comical like did you hear
that from 17 billion to eight hundred
billion dollar is insane in a 12 month
year I mean that's absolutely ridiculous
inflation and there had to be some sort
of correction and consequently what you
saw was enormous mainstream interest you
couldn't turn on CNBC without seeing
cardano's price flicker across you
couldn't go and turn on Bloomberg or Fox
Business without seeing the same thing
people want to know where is - today it
people were having these inane
conversations as to why like these not
even technical conversations why they
were these price movements in crypto
these no one cared about crypto at the
time are six months before that they had
no idea what they were talking about on
TV and I think that led to a lot of the
overhyped that we saw and it led to a
lot of companies starting that shouldn't
have started in the first place but
today the people who've been working in
blockchain have often been working for a
number of years they may have worked on
other projects before they've seen
what's worked and what doesn't they've
seen how things have pivoted and I'm
telling you I'm seeing a lot of very
interesting stuff today that I think is
gonna be very compelling products and
services six months a year from now
absolutely what um what do you think is
kind of the next 12 months of crypto in
the mainstream media look like right do
you see that interest kind of as it's
waned over the last 1214 months in the
bear market do you see that recovering
do you see it kind of like there's just
more rational coverage or how does that
play out well there are definitely some
reporters who have had let's call it
blockchain disinterest they've just seen
too much they've had over exposure we
recently had in my New York office two
reporters from a major business
publication come in to give us a Lunch
and Learn and they talked with all of
our staff about what they found
interesting today and they had seen so
many pitches over time and they were
just saying look if it's not something
unbelievably compelling we don't care it
has to be something that's completely
groundbreaking we've seen it all people
pitching us solutions to every one of
life's problems from vaccines we'll be
cured by this new coin - we're gonna
change the way the fish on your menu is
marketed essentially and sold and the
price of it and we're gonna do it
overnight and these miracle cures never
came about so I'd say in general
mainstream reporters they
have lost any if they ever had any
optimism in a panacea like product for
crypto but they are compelled by how
substantial it has become we're
certainly seeing with Bitcoin with ether
and I think with a couple of other major
let's call them top coins we're seeing
that those are real financial products
and then we're seeing that reporters are
interested in defy we're seeing that
they are interested in securities meets
blockchain they're seeing a lot of
interest there and I think that the
sophistication of the players in the
market how helps to substantiate that
and make it actually newsworthy you know
it's interesting to the the idea that
like most crypto companies pitch
themselves as crypto companies but a lot
of them actually they use blockchain or
they use some sort of decentralization
or just River ledger technology but
they're not really a crypto company I
like that like they may actually better
off not presenting them that that way
because you know many people know that
my girlfriend is a reporter at Fortune
magazine and yeah you see just like the
the eyes glaze over when a lot of these
reporters you know not just unfortunate
just many of the publications the second
they hear Bitcoin blockchain crypto it's
like yeah like got like I've been there
I've heard that I'm not interested and
so do you see that as a strategy people
are employing where they just start to
almost de-emphasize the Bitcoin and
blockchain part of it or is that still
kind of the core to some of the
communication strategies so there are
many times where we'll simply say you're
a fin tech company and we want you to
use the word blockchain it turns out
that if you want to go through their
tech stack you're gonna find blockchain
somewhere in there yep but this person
telling if you are if you're working on
some sort of real estate deal that
happens to use blockchain as the way
that your security essentially is formed
what's interesting is the real estate
project it's where it's situated it's
how what the IRR is gonna look like
that's what's interesting not the fact
that it happens to be using some sort of
blockchain for trading and settlement
down the road no one cares
so make the story about what's actually
interesting we do this all the time with
companies and I think the great thing
about blockchain is in extremely
extremely horizontal technology and I
don't want people to
that you and I are up here hating on
blockchain
it's a incredible technology and you and
I have talked a lot about that it's
applicable to not everything but a whole
lot of things and it's gonna go and
change the way a lot of industries work
but it's it itself is not the only
solution it's just a technology that
allows for better products and services
to exist and I think that we need to
make the focus more about that then on
the fact that they're using a type of
distributed ledger tech that's it no I
think that makes a lot of sense you
earlier mentioned New York office but
you guys have offices in Dublin in
Singapore how does some of the media
coverage and or quality of companies
change when you get outside the United
States what does it look like in some
other markets so the Dublin office
essentially services EMEA clients and
the Singapore office services APEC
clients not the media they're what's
very important is our New York staff
pitches to the South China Morning Post
the Irish staff pitches to the Los
Angeles Times just as much as they may
pitch in within their own geographies so
we service clients based on where were
most proximate timezone wise to where
the client is because we want to have as
many hours in the day to work with that
client as humanly possible but yes we
certainly see coverage everywhere and we
see companies evolve everywhere over the
last six months I've spent the vast
majority of the time outside the United
States I've been I most recently was in
Paris and Dublin before that I've been
in Singapore and Hong Kong and across
Europe and I spent this time working
with not just my offices in these
different locations but with companies
and seeing kind of what's happening
outside of the US outside of Canada and
what I found is is that there was an
enormous amount of hype that occurred in
Asia in so I'd say end of 2017 fully
2018 the interest disintegrated far
faster there than anywhere else I think
not enough people are talking about
Europe right now these what we're seeing
there are really great projects really
great progress Europeans and I know I'm
painting an entire continent with a
broad brush they tend to be more
understated and less likely to hype
things up
I fear gonna see great things coming out
of Europe this year in crypto yeah
nothing like some Americans to to really
rally up the troops and get some hype
before before the actual substance well
we're the kings of tech and
publicity right we've got Silicon Valley
yeah and we've got here in New York so I
think it's very easy to under 8 what's
happening elsewhere in the globe it's
also very hard to pay attention to
everything at once given the amount of
noise amount of players but again watch
Europe yeah I mean look I'll give an
example of a company you know you take
like an e Toro right if you take eToro
versus a Robin Hood they both help
customers go ahead and purchase
different types of assets in a consumer
friendly you know kind of mobile or
consumer friendly experience
everyone knows Robin Hood in North
America but eToro is actually bigger
right when you look at the financials
and the the types of assets they offer
etc and I think it's a great example of
you've got a European based company that
probably actually would be better known
simply by having you know being based in
different geography which is which is
pretty crazy to think about
it's amazing you can't walk in London
without seeing an eToro sign somewhere
it might be the air bus seat has eToro
on it
they're just gigantic in Europe and
we've been very very lucky to launch
eToro in the United States and eta I
forgot about that yeah and eToro X
actually was launched just last week in
Paris what we're seeing which is their
new exchange everyone should hahahaha oh
man I threw a softball the Twitter
trolls are gonna be all over the guy
just gave him a [ __ ] in the softball
that's a very good case they were not
known at all the Astro reporter for
instance in San Francisco about eToro a
year ago they'd say who but if you talk
to someone in London or if you talk to
someone in Berlin they would all know
who that is because it's a platform that
lots of people were using not even
freely for crypto although they they
actually have Oh G crypto roots you know
like the the CEO actually wrote the
color coins paper with Vitalik way back
and wild yeah why us but they were best
known for of course the social trading
of securities and commodities and
effects but coming to United States has
been a challenge because no one had
heard who they were and they knew about
these other trading platforms they've
been using them
they've been familiar with them and
they're brokerages so I think that
shifting on to something new is going to
be a challenge but what we've seen with
eToro and I and I obviously I'm a big
believer and Weavin working with
over a year now is that they are they've
got the tools to really mark it well and
I think we'll probably see a lot of
exciting stuff this year
yeah the we actually had unis on the
podcast at one point and when he was
going over the just early days of
writing colored coin the vitalik say I'm
gonna go start aetherium and him big I
don't know I'm probably gonna build
eToro
uh-huh he's it tells some great stories
and laughing about it so it's cool all
right so last question for you before
you get into rapid fire is what's the
one thing that you wish founders would
walk away after hearing kind of all of
these tips etc in terms of I'm a founder
and I'm thinking about communication
marketing you know PR etc what's the one
thing I need to know you need to look
outside yourself spend time thinking
about and when I do diligence on
companies one of the questions I ask
that most investors don't ask is who are
your perceived competitors and the
reason I ask that is a lot of companies
think that they are the only ones
servicing a certain market but reporters
are inherently going to bucket you in
some way shape or form with others if
you can't find a way of delivering
uniqueness and differentiation from
those perceived competitors you're not
gonna have an edge you're never gonna go
and get the press that you want and if
you don't get the press you want you may
not be able to meet your business
objectives that is one thing the second
most important thing is realize that PR
advertising marketing in general is a
tool to meet business objectives do not
think about exposure for its own sake
brand for its own sake it needs to get
somewhere if you can't determine what
business objectives PR and marketing can
help you get or or region then you're
never gonna go and be satisfied with the
ROI and spend on it whether you're
hiring internal staff hiring external
agencies to devoting your own energy and
time to it because it's a huge
investment PR requires if you're a
founder that you're going to be doing
interviews you're going to be approving
articles they're gonna be approving
press releases that you're gonna be
fact-checking things it's a huge
investment but if you don't have those
business objectives clearly outlined
it's gonna be a huge waste of time got
it what um rapid-fire for you what's the
most important company encrypt other
than your
I'd say digital currency group because I
think they're everywhere
okay it meaning that they just have
their hands in so much different stuff
they Barry and his team were very very
early or very very smart and managed to
go and invest in a lot of the most
important companies that we know today I
saw a report recently I think they did
over a hundred million dollars in
revenue with aid employees at the parent
company unbelievable yeah it's pretty
insane what's the one regulation you
would change or improve if you could oh
man he told me not to ask about any
regulations so I can't get away from the
rapid fire clock well I'm here in New
York and the bitlicense has been
something that I think is has been
proven onerous of the first 22 companies
that you know it's not a rapid answer
that applied for a bit license to or my
clients at the time one took over three
years to get approved Wow they did
absolutely everything right they had the
world's best lawyers the world's best
client's team took over three years to
get a bit license if it takes more than
three years to go and operate a business
and if you're basically are building on
a pending bit license a business that
depends on the outcome being a positive
one people are going to take risks like
that and I think New York should not be
essentially compelling companies encrypt
are really good ones to not operate here
so I hope that if anything the DFS
becomes a better partner to making sure
that the best companies and only the
best are able to operate here in New
York for sure what uh what's the most
controversial thought you have in terms
of something you believe that everyone
else Oh disagree with you on hmm don't
disappoint
I like the ripple guys I don't think
that well there's a lot of people who
will complain and say that they may not
like ripple they may not like XRP but in
terms of the people behind the company
my whole thing is how do you not like
somebody you've never met before right
you're not that you don't have to like
them right for all the people on the
internet like you're not necessarily
like somebody but you can't not like
them well you've had a conversation well
let me let me expand on that a little
further right a lot of people look at
ripple and they say that's not a
blockchain okay okay
but I don't think that something has to
be a blockchain
for to be interesting mm-hmm independent
of that we need to make the conversation
a little bit broader things can be
blockchain like and that's cool is a dag
a blockchain by itself there are all
these new structures coming out what had
we were used to and talking about
Bitcoin just proof-of-work
what happens when your sharding when
you're using pre mistake when you have
all these really compelling new systems
five years from now ten years from now
who knows what the architectures gonna
look like but if we only allow ourselves
to like a very small subset of
technologies and everything outside of
that is the enemy I think we're looking
at it wrong for sure okay that's fair
what's the most important book you've
ever read man probably some sort of
history book I'd say I don't know which
one exactly but I love history books and
I love fiction I think literature is
incredibly underrated today people read
news articles they read what's on reddit
but very few people are actually reading
fiction anymore you know I about two
weeks ago I went to Barnes and Nobles
here in Union Square and it was like a
graveyard there was no one there the
only people buying anything were buying
gifts basically they weren't buying
actual books they were buying the junky
things you sell on the side and people
who consequently I don't think you're
reading fiction as much as they should
that's what gives you a command of
language and command of language I think
is necessary and essentially anything
you do especially of course encom's
do you have a favorite fiction book I
really loved Holst away I love the way
that he's able to tell history and make
it compelling while at the same time
fully explain the human condition from a
number of different perspectives all
right guys how about aliens and then you
can ask you one question to wrap this up
do you believe or not I do
I absolutely believe there's got to be
something else out there all right it's
a very big world and the one sad thing
I'd say is that SETI at home doesn't
have nearly enough hash power today
because all those people turn to mining
Bitcoin ether and everything else so we
may never find the aliens and it's
entirely due to Bitcoin yeah that's
pretty good what about the depths of the
ocean right so so here's a here's my
thing is everyone always talks about
space aliens they started coming
prepared for that question so then I
started thinking well we actually know
more about you know the Moon or Mars
than we do our own oceans are you James
Cameron uh no no but but here's the
thing that actually started to scare me
a little bit
now people send me these articles write
on aliens on the oceans whatever there's
some wild [ __ ] in the ocean like bit
like the whole like Loch Ness monster
thing right that's not necessary the
ocean but the idea that there's like so
kind of creature that we haven't seen or
we rarely see and we don't really
understand etc that's like fact in the
ocean there I've seen I probably a four
five EBU sent me these articles and
there's things that kind of look like a
shark but sort of like a Blowfish but
sort of like a seal you know like
whatever I'm just fascinated by the fact
that you know we spent all this time
looking up in the sky and you can get in
that ocean you have no clue what's down
there well the way I look at it is just
think about the resources that are there
that we can utilize there is what 70% of
where earth is covered in the water like
that yeah
so essentially because we're so bad at
going down we're not very good at
building types of vessels to go down
there in mind we're not able to go and
get some readily available resources or
nearly readily available resources that
we could use to make life for humans
much much much better so I think
certainly we're gonna see a lot of tech
going towards that and investment
towards that in the future but look you
got to find a profit of what you're an
investor would you put tons of money to
something that's extremely high risk
that there's no necessarily way to get
your money back
well maybe I shouldn't be asking you
that you shouldn't ask me this is
exactly what I do and that's essentially
what it's like to invest in these types
of ocean mining companies yeah well and
I think also you know Adam Draper came
on and he was talking about you know
building these islands basically where
there's you know kind of all new rules
and and monetary systems etc and build
the ocean but there's this billionaire
have you heard about this guy's he's
like one of the five hundred people in
the world or whatever his whole thing is
he wants to reach the deepest point of
all seven seas oceans and he's gone to
like three or four of them and he builds
single man submarines and like my whole
thing is like I get it ready to be cool
I go down far in the ocean but like the
deepest point in the ocean it's just
feels like there's so much pressure down
there that like your submarine cracks
you're done like there's just no coming
back right so that having been said I
kind of get it I really do want in my
life time to leave this planet even I'm
just going to orbit but the club of
people in the history of the world who
have ever left Earth and looked back is
very very small yeah and I believe as
humans we are compelled to be explorers
yep that's why we've reached and found
absolutely everything that there's
defined on this earth we've tried and
why we're gonna go into the Stars as
well it's something that compels us it
gives us a reason beyond ourselves to be
part of that initial Club I mean that's
that's something that I want to do when
I'm what about you are you gonna go to
space I would go for sure I've been
thinking more for a number of years I
would go do something crazy every year
usually grab one of my brothers and go
and I haven't done one in I think two
years now
so I've been thinking more about what to
do I've got one of our founders who will
go unnamed he made an investment and he
texted me after we made the investment
it said by the way I don't tell
investors this till they've invested but
I run ultra marathons in my free time
like you made a good bet and so he's
been trying to get me to go run one of
these like hundred mile races which it's
crazy but I guess running and you know
I've been a mayor I actually did the
original marathon in Greece and that
sucked because it was far so running
four times farther doesn't exactly
appease to me but I don't know I'll come
up with something and then maybe I'll
come on and I'll tell ya if you could
run a marathon in space now that would
be a newsworthy and compelling story
I'll tell you what you'd have like what
I guess on the moon it would be harder
because of zero gravity right to run a
marathon yeah but runs right you can
probably just like hop yeah your body
wouldn't hurt as much no maybe that's
the thing to do is train to be an
astronaut and go run a marathon on the
moon you think we went to the moon
absolutely all right III know some
people who actually don't believe that
and I always joke with them like why do
you believe that and the best response
I've ever heard was a how come we can't
see the flag how can we can't see the
flag yeah the flag that got planted
nearly like a million miles away or ever
far away the moon is there like it with
all the telescopes we have why can't you
see the flag obviously they're being
ridiculous but all right listen
enough with the aliens I appreciate you
you coming on I think that a lot of
people will get a you know value out of
just hearing kind of your perspective
you deal with this stuff every day and
I think it's just misunderstood by a lot
of folks so thanks so much you'll have
to have you come back on in a little bit
thanks for having me pomp